this is a guy that's so Infamous
everyone in America probably knows his
name but no one knows that he committed
Financial crimes oh he's a sex
trafficker that's what we need he's just
a sex trafficker no he's a finance but
this is the guy that was involved in one
of the biggest Ponzi schemes in U.S
history with Towers Financial even
though he was named as being The
Mastermind of that during grand jury
proceedings his name is dropped from the
case and he ends up at Bill Clinton
fundraisers in 1993. and then after that
some of the most controversial
fundraisers in Bill Clinton's uh
presidential career Epstein's there and
then after Clinton leaves office he's
setting up the Clinton Foundation
flooring on Epstein's plane around
Africa he credits Epstein for coming up
with his HIV AIDS philanthropy uh being
involved in creating the Clinton Health
Access initiative you know and a lot of
people have sort of you know argued that
the Clinton Foundation is sort of a
glorified political slush fund for the
Clinton family so why do you have a
financial criminal helping you set up
your your foundation